cansados pero sonrientes los alumnos
nigerianos regresaron a casa todavía con
sus uniformes pero varios descalza dos
los menores que fueron secuestrados en
el noroeste de nigeria fueron liberados
el viernes después de un calvario de
seis días
344 estudiantes han sido entregados a la
agencia de seguridad los examinaremos
médicamente y se harán los trámites para
reunirlos con sus familias
no está claro si aún hay algún alumno
privado de la libertad en efecto a
principios del día de ayer un vídeo
supuestamente del grupo yihadista de
bucarám mostraba a un adolescente
angustiado que desea estar entre 520
estudiantes secuestrados tampoco se sabe
si hubo cuarán llevó a cabo la redada lo
que marcaría una expansión de su
territorio o si bandas criminales
armadas conocidas localmente como
bandidos podrían haberlos vendido a los
insurgentes islámicos los escolares
fueron raptados el viernes pasado de la
escuela secundaria en casi nada por
pistoleros en motocicletas que los
llevaron al bus
derrumbo y fueron liberados casi una
semana después luego de negociaciones
con el gobierno ocurrió en medio de
violentas manifestaciones contra la
administración del presidente muhammadu
buhari motivadas por la inseguridad en
el norte del país
nigeria ha sido abandonada hoy a la
merced de insurgentes viciosos bandidos
secuestradores ladrones armados
violadores y un surtido de criminales
empedernidos que deambulan y operan con
facilidad
el secuestro se ha apoderado de una
nación ya indignada por la inseguridad
generalizada trayendo consigo dolorosos
recuerdos de las alumnas de chivo
secuestradas por bucarám en 2014